[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en ce cinquième centenaire de la mort de
léonard de vinci
non loin de là où nous sommes de ce soir
j'ai décidé de venir vous parler de
celle qui à mon avis est la plus grande
révolution que léonard a jamais réalisé
dans l'histoire de l'art plus
généralement dans l'histoire de
l'humanité
il s'agit pas d'une invention
technologique d'une révolution
technologique mais du regard particulier
unique et novateur que léonard pour ta
sur la femme donna représenta les femmes
de façon complètement différente
complètement éloigné par rapport aux
stéréotypes au canon de son époque et il
a ainsi rendu aux femmes une vraiment
une dignité nouvelle je parle de
révolution alors c'est vrai qu'une image
on est cuit surface d'une épaisseur de
quelques millimètres quelque chose de
frasil de petits et pourtant représenter
une chose différemment veut dire penser
une chose différemment et une pensée
peut déclencher ce processus de
changement de la société et donc une
image est comme une arme non violente
qui peut vraiment changer le monde bat
comme un ted ce soir avant de regarder
comment les honneurs représenter les
femmes je voudrais vous reprises vous
montrer comment l'époque de léonard
représenter traditionnellement les
femmes et j'ai choisi donc un
chef-d'oeuvre de raphaël que vous
connaissez peut-être est-ce que c'est un
tableau très connu qui d'ailleurs
s'inspire un peu de la joconde dans la
position des mains et dans la mise en
page de la composition que raphaël
connaissait parce qu'il avait fréquenté
ce moment là l'atelier de léonard
cette femme est la femme idéale de la
renaissance c'est à dire une très bonne
affaire elle a apporté à son mari une
dot très importante elle a fait un très
bon mariage avec un marchand et
d'ailleurs cela est dit clairement par
ses vêtements qui attire tout de suite
notre attention
ces vêtements précieux mais aussi ses
bijoux important que les civilisations
symbolique et par exemple la perle qui
pend sur sa poitrine est un symbole de
la fidélité un bertu maritale
fondamental pour une femme évidemment
une fidélité qui sera pas réciproque 1
voilà
mais la chose qui nous frappe vraiment
qu'on regarde ce tableau c'est en
réalité le regard de cette femme
ce sont des yeux qui voient sans
regarder cette femme finalement est un
objet massif de notre observation mais
elle ne change pas avec nous elle est un
objet léonard à cette représentation de
la femme était très ancrée 1 de l'époque
de léonard et même le nardant son
premier portrait de femme finalement à
peu près interpréter ce type d'image
vous voyez que cette femme
qu'aujourd'hui on a pu identifier grâce
aux buissons de gêner vrie et qui est
derrière elle qui évoque par assonances
le prénom du livre la banshee nous
apparaît froid à des de marbre très
distantes
ce regard aussi évident mais néanmoins
léonard déjà à ce moment là à regarder
nous sommes vingt ans avant le portege
même plus que le conseil je vous ai
montré tout à leur honneur essaye
d'innover
il n'accepte pas que cette femme puisse
ne pas avoir un monde intérieur et donc
il se sert de ce stratagème je dirais le
premier c'est l'interaction non pas avec
le spectateur
mais avec le paysage la froideur quelque
part de cette femme semble envahir le
paysage et le congelé en
une atmosphère d'automne même les
feuillages des arbres deviennent oranges
et un peu couleurs du miel comme les
cheveux les bouclettes de geneva la
couleur de ses yeux et même regarder le
bleu qui est utilisé pour le font
exactement le même pour cette ok de
glacial exactement le même du ruban qui
sert sa robe
mais voilà d'une eva ce regard baissé
comme tous les manuels de l'époque de
bonne éducation de jeune fille disait
que devait être le regard d'une femme
c'est à dire les paupières un peu baissé
pour jamais rencontré directement le
regard de leurs époux en signe
d'humilité de modestie et surtout de
soumission mais dîner la chose très
particulier à si nos comptes par an avec
le tableau je vous ai montré tout à
l'heure elle l'honneur prend à parti un
peu particulier pourtant les dîners
appartenait familles fortunées elle a un
très beau vêtement mais vous voyez elle
n'a aucun bijou si nous voulons savoir
pourquoi
retournons le tableau et nous verrons
derrière la réponse est bien il ya un
écriteau latin qui nous dit qu'elle est
la forme à la beauté de cette femme est
décoré par sa vertu fait l'ornement
cette femme et sa beauté et donc sa
vraie présence est vrai et bray sens
c'est sa vertu scène son monde intérieur
ces femmes qui à qui nous invite à
découvrir qui est derrière cette image
cette apparence mais ça sera à milan que
l'ona réalisera ce que j'appelle le
premier portrait d'une femme
intelligente de toute l'histoire de
l'art et regarde un petit peu comme mon
affaire florence et la situation des
femmes de la représentation des femmes à
milan c'est encore pire qu'à florence
parce que vous voyez à milan on n'aime
pas le paysage donc le fond et noir et
on aime le portrait de profil donc
aucune interaction avec nous et donc
cette froideur cette distance encore
plus forte encore plus importante
et voyez si cette femme c'est infâme
objets avec tous ses bijoux qui la
recouvre la tête aux pieds
rien à voir avec ce portrait de cecina
galets dan la dame à l'hermine dont elle
a aussi un jeu de mots nous permet de
l'identification parce que vous savez
que l'hermine engrais que l'irg allait
donc ghalebani et cette femme fait
partie d'un triangle camps protagonistes
d'un triangle de regard la regardons
mais cécilia regard de quelqu'un d'autre
de façon active et en plus je dirais
elle est en train d'accomplir une action
précise elle écoute son interlocuteur
mais elle est en train de réfléchir déjà
à sa réponse et c'est une femme qui a le
sens de la répartie d'ailleurs ce
qu'elle est en train de penser l'a fait
à même un tout petit peu sourire un
loyal et les bosses un petit sourire
mais une chose qui me font remarquer
souvent mes étudiants me disais pourquoi
elle a une main aussi disproportionnée
cette femme c'est vrai je sais pas si
vous avez remarqué
et c'est vrai que c'est un peu typique
des artistes qu'ils soient issus d'une
formation florentine
d'ailleurs je sais pas si ça vous est
venu à l'esprit mais aussi un autre
grand chef-d'oeuvre florentin la vie de
michel-ange présente cette disproportion
de la main pourquoi parce qu'à florence
on croyait que la main on disait la main
c'est l'outil de l'intellect et celui
qui permet à la pensée de hal et de
l'esprit de être traduites en actions
et qu'est-ce qu'elle fait donc cette
main de cette femme qui est activement
intelligente elle retient et caresse en
même temps retient à près de son coeur
c'est hermine l'hermine acquis et
symbole de ludovic le more seigneur de
milan le mort à cause de sa peau mate
mais dont les vertus été comparée à
celle de la blanche hermine
donc c'est une femme qui avec la force
ses pensées la force de son intellect
retient à côté d'elle à côté de son
coeur comme un prisonnier voyez un quart
est en même temps et retient son amant
léonard poussera encore plus
au delà de ses limites à cette réflexion
sur la femme dans la classe écrivent
elles la deuxième maîtresse de ludovic
le more qui est l'image même de la
séduction ici léonard renonce à tous et
renonce au fond parce que c'est un faux
noir y renonce aux mains vous les voyez
pas ils sont cachés derrière un parapet
il renonce à la couleur parce que ce
tableau pratiquement monochrome il ya
que du rouge qu'est la couleur la
passion amoureuse
toute l'attention du spectateur doit se
focaliser et ensorcelé par ce beau gars
qui exprime une force d'un ami longtemps
cité de caractère exceptionnel
c'est l'image même de la séduction qui
élisait un poète qui est que j'aime
beaucoup
hikmet dans le moment même où j'ai
l'impression d'avoir saisi jeu devient
inaccessible
et d'ailleurs ce regard qui nous
appellent inverse vers cette femme est
un regard qui échappent toujours pas ce
que vous voyez les légèrement tournée
vers la gauche
ce sera à florence revenant qui tombe il
a en florence kelowna réalise son plus
grands chefs-d'oeuvre
et là le portrait de lisa il faut que je
vous raconte tout petit peu l'histoire
du mari de lise francesco del giocondo
quand jusqu'au jour où on avait déjà eu
avant lisa deux autres mariages quitté
des mariages traditionnels ils avaient
des mariages d'intérêt et lisse en
revance le mariage avec les était
différent c'est un mariage d'amour parce
que elle n'avait pas une fortune
familiale et le 9 et 1 soit vraiment
révolutionnaire au lieu de représenter
cette femme avec les symboles les signes
de cette statue social quels acquis
grâce à son mariage il nous représente
un femme complètement dépourvu même si
avec un très bel habit vert
maintenant elle est noire parce que le
tableau faut le dire et le restaurer
mais il nous représente une femme qui a
pas de bijoux comme vous le voyez la
valeur de cette femme ce qui justifie
son l'amour de son époux elle l'humanité
profonde qu'elle exprime qu'elle dégage
avec ce regard une humanité qui
s'exprime dans ce paysage voyez immense
comme justement l'âme profonde de cette
femme et qui exprime évidemment à
travers ce regard qui veut nous dire
quelque chose que tout le monde a
l'impression de connaître mona lisa et
on a l'impression que mona lisa nous
connaissent
et qu'il veille le dire quelque chose
léonard a innové à représenter cet
univers infini riche fascinant de la
femme son intelligence à sa force de
caractère son humanité
mais on peut se demander pourquoi
comment se fait-il qu'il y en aura eu 7
cette intuition exceptionnelle il faut
dire qu'il est on à la seule femme de sa
vie la première même si la seule parce
qu'il n'a jamais eu de femme à ses côtés
était une femme aussi atypique catherine
on connaît seulement son prénom sa maman
était peut-être une paysanne peut être
une esclave c'est pas très bien en tout
cas ses mérites était autre que les
mérites de la naissance ou du statut
social est d'ailleurs justement sur ce
sujet de la maternité
léonard aussi restituer aux femmes une
une dignité et une valeur que leur
époque ne reconnaissait pas pendant la
période romaine donc la dernière étape
avant de venir en france et leone a fait
des études de biologie et développe une
pensée complètement novatrice où le rôle
de la femme dans la création
on croyait à l'époque que la femme était
à juste un conteneur comme une terre
inertes dans laquelle germait créé cette
semence masculine qui est le contenu et
l'esprit vital est en selle mittal mais
en réalité
leonardi c'est la femme c'est le corps
de la femme qui construit qui est créée
la matrice de lui là le corps de
l'enfant
et chose encore plus exceptionnel il
dira c'est la femme qui des stalles à
nîmes qui éveille la main de l'enfant
ce n'est pas dieu comment croyez à
l'époque et d'ailleurs il a eu la
mauvaise idée de le dire juste à rome il
a été dénoncé donc à la cour à portiques
à le séjour à rome n'a pas été des plus
heureux pour léonard et d'ailleurs il
quittera l'italie est comme vous le
savez ils viennent mourir en france ces
regards de femmes pourtant beaucoup de
choses à nous dire encore aujourd'hui je
crois que dans le
dans le domaine de la du progrès
technologique en effet nous avons
réalisé presque tous les rêves de
léonard l'avion le compteur de
kilomètres les l'hélicoptère le masque
et tuba et pourtant ces images exprime
un projet humain qui me semblent n'a pas
encore entièrement étaient réalisés dans
la société dans le monde d'aujourd'hui
yona rue sensibilité vraiment
exceptionnel pour tout les êtres de
l'univers même pour les animaux et l'été
végétarien on dit qu'il a acheté des des
oiseaux en cage pour ouvrir la cage et
les laisser voler à libre en l'air et
donc il est impensable qu'ils n'aient
pas eu une sensibilité pour le statut de
la femme pour la condition de la femme
de son époque
donc comme je disais ces images sont un
projet quelque part pour l'humanité qui
me semblent n'est pas encore aujourd'hui
entièrement réalisés contrairement à
l'avion l'hélicoptère etc
et je ne pense pas seulement à ces
femmes qui n'ont pas le droit de
regarder dans les yeux de leurs
interlocuteurs dans certains pays du
monde mais je pense à notre société
occidentale où le corps de la femme est
utilisée parfois privé de son regard des
façons les plus humiliantes pour des
buts publicitaires et ou alors à
l'atelier du façon voilà mille ans
génial et donc je pense que si léonard
fut un artiste universel l'universalité
de son message devrait traverser le
temps traversé les siècles et à seule
fois que nous croisons le regard de la
seconde à surfer que nous croisons le
regard d'une femme
nous devrions
pensez à ce projet de l'ona paula pour
l'humanité a ce regard qui fut celui de
de léonard sur les femmes
et si ce ne fut qu'un rêve
le réaliser aujourd'hui serait peut-être
le plus beau cadeau que nous pourrions
faire à léonard en son anniversaire mais
aussi à nous elle était toute entière
voilà
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]